okay so the new trailer for stranger
things season 4 just came out and it
looks absolutely crazy there's roller
rinks there's dungeons and dragons
there's a russian prison and at one
point the night king from game of
thrones even shows up this season is
definitely going to be the wildest one
we've seen yet so let's dive in to see
what exactly we can expect from stranger
things season 4.
[Music]
the trailer opens with journeys separate
ways world apart perfect for the split
worlds and stranger things between the
normal world and the upside down then we
hear a disembodied voice say your
suffering is almost at an end right
before seeing a flash of what looks
pretty much like the night king from
game of thrones so we can expect this
monster to be the big bad of the show
just based upon its appearance we then
see max at a grave and we're reminded
that billy unfortunately is now dead if
you remember billy redeemed himself at
the end of season 3 sacrificing himself
to protect the kids next we get a pretty
cool inverted shot of a crime scene
where a body is being taken away
reminding us of the ever present upside
down all around us we see that l is now
attending school with their friends and
then we see a shot of a grandfather
clock stuck in a wall the same clock
that we saw at the beginning of the
trailer so this item will likely be
pretty significant in the story and
could have some pretty strong
implications for max since she's the one
we see interacting with the clock we
then see hopper in a russian prison in
what looks like a very cold winter and
then a shot of the kids skating around a
roller rink which is just perfect for
the 80s vibes this show gives off we're
then told that they had all been
relocated far away from hawkins to
california for their safety but that
they're going to be pulled back into the
craziness they thought they left in
hawkins elle says she doesn't have her
powers anymore but she's still taken
away there seems to be somewhat of a
supernatural war going down and for some
reason they need the kids to help out
then we get a ton of shots that
completely embody the 80s and the
characters hairstyles and outfits in
just a perfect way we see hopper being
tortured in the russian prison and then
hopper actually fighting alongside the
other inmates against a demogorgon that
seems to have found its way into the
prison then we get a flashback to when
elle was still in captivity seemingly
just after killing some guards with
blood running down her face next we get
a series of quick shots all together
starting with max levitating perhaps
meaning that she's gaining some
supernatural powers that'll help them
fight in this war in the upside down we
then see steve killing monsters in the
upside down you know as he does along
with some person playing an electric
guitar in the upside down and i
absolutely can't wait to see how on
earth this electric guitar solo is going
to play into the plot of the show we
then get a quick shot of a blind guy
with his eyes scratched out and then a
shot of a plane crash with joyce inside
along with murray perhaps on their way
to rescue hopper from prison then we see
a demogorgon slowly reaching out towards
joyce in a quick shot some surreal shots
in the upside down and then a new
terrifying looking monster perhaps the
new leader of the evil supernatural
forces taking over hawkins this monster
is definitely the creepiest we've seen
in the show so far and i think it's
probably going to be the most
threatening one too although it'll
probably be hard to top the mind flayer
okay so after going through all the
shots in the trailer we can definitely
tell that this is gonna be a season to
remember max potentially getting powers
joyce rescuing hopper from prison a
random electric guitar solo in the
upside down the night king a disturbing
grandfather clock a blind guy and so
much more await us in stranger things
season 4. i have absolutely no idea how
they're gonna fit all of these crazy
shots into one season of television if
there's one thing for certain though
it's that these kids aren't out of the
woods just yet they're definitely to get
wrapped up in the supernatural craziness
surrounding hawkins no matter how far
they move away we'll just have to wait
and see exactly how far they get wrapped
up into it when the show releases in
just a couple of months with the first
volume streaming on may 27th and the
second volume on july 1st anyways that's
gonna be all for today if you like what
you saw maybe check out the video on
your screen for some different content i
make videos on basically anything that
interests me in the world of
entertainment also don't forget to like
and subscribe as it truly does help me
out and thanks for watching rocketry
[Music]